another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation dr bride is  not allowed to play hippocratic oath  chicken with the medical staff the  hippocratic oath is deeply important to  all medical professionals including  those on staff at the scp foundation dr  bright is not permitted to try and  convince the medical staff to break the  hippocratic oath in any way he is  especially not allowed to expose them to  potentially dangerous anomalies while  taunting still want to do no harm you  sure it's a waste of time resources and  it's just plain rude one of these days  they're going to snap and slap him  across the face and not one of us will  stop them